mmm-hmm whatever you're doing no Julian
dink-dink welcome back to the Julian
podcast we only need one Mike in this
house let's share Mike's but we actually
used to do that talk about later this
episode is brought to you by classpass
guys class fast is a way to work out and
not get bored with one gym or one style
of workouts they offer many different
types of training access to over 15,000
of the best gyms and fitness studios all
over the world right now go to class
pass calm / try / general Julian that
clas s PA SS dongs last try / Angela or
hit the link below your fitness game
will be leveled up also guys me on these
best underwear most comfortable three
times softer than cotton me wear every
single day
proud supporter of the podcast try the
new boxer brief with the fly easy access
you know what I mean check it out at me
andis calm / Jenna Julian for 15% off
your first pair free shipping in 100%
satisfaction guarantee I also got
Squarespace if you're looking to build a
website do with Squarespace no better
way to do it 24/7 customer support
over 200,000 companies use Squarespace
be like them go to squarespace.com slash
annejulien and check it out for a free
trial or you get 10% off of your first
purchase of a website or domain with
that link hmm remember way back when I
unplug my mic that one time I talk to me
your mic yeah it reminded me that how
long have we been podcasting it feels
like really long do you remember we used
to have the mic we had one mic for a
while we did one mic we won't we USB we
one mic did no it was um it was it was a
USB mic it was not you know let me know
let me know let me know so you can see
where okay no this is a tarp it is the
time because I was the one processing
all the
reason in your tooth right now I don't
yes you do you burn camera until you see
your teeth isn't your front teeth cut he
walks up to me earlier with a little box
of where he sits not even there snacking
a little box of raisins they're just so
cute because I haven't seen those since
I was like a kid those like my snack a
little juice box nature's candy box or
raisins
anyways you missed a really enjoy it's
like in your teeth would it have been
impossible to enjoy if it didn't get
stuck in my teeth no is there a
correlation between food stuck in teeth
and enjoyment of a meal no we started
the podcast with those do SP mics and
then when we graduated to the XLR AKG
mic that we used to use before we got
these we remember I set up on this
camera the wide lens and I put it like
right here and one of our arms was
always huge and I was like oh what
happened to genna's aren't you know we
put one mic in the center of us for like
most of those podcast it was like a
stretch of like 10 podcasts I think so
we can do it if you want wait I don't
want to do it just try it that's making
a terrible sound
yeah well potato potato it is called out
and what why don't you tell them what
you did this morning okay
yesterday I'm like editing my video and
I'm like getting really tired I'm just
saying they're like trying to power
through my day and Julian's like writing
up a shot list and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is that you want to get out of a
pool in a suit with an umbrella
inspiration strikes in many ways and
sometimes a very random times but I and
also I think I'll touch on this later
but I think the the my schedule lately
with streams and the amount of videos
I'm making it lends itself more to me
putting more thought and time into a
video than I used to
I had an idea last night that because
last year I didn't re-season vlog where
I was just being very Aries in the vlog
Alert red alert
yeah which kind of you know I wouldn't
say you know I wouldn't say started but
definitely like propelled the meme of
being me being like the Aries you know
who's wild and everything and I thought
to myself like what can I do this year
that's not just like a vlog you know
it's also kind of hard to vlog after a
million years of logging because there's
only so much you know you can really
share do something new so I was thinking
like what could I do and I just for some
reason couldn't get this shot out of my
head of a man emerging from a pool
preferably with with bad weather led
first by an umbrella just like a slow
emerging out of the water right like
something out of just a weird movie but
no one rents and it sits on the shelf
until blockbuster just gets it out oh
you mean like devil by M night Shyamalan
I have on blockbuster DVD not like
double cuz someone did rent it aka this
guy who didn't return it do what you
want
blockbuster that's mine and you can't
get it back we don't even have a DVD
player but I'm keeping it
devil is a good movie hopefully my dad's
not still getting billed your dad is
still getting billed for dunno he dreams
that I can't find him oh how that works
yeah
blockbuster didn't have and they didn't
have computers no oh they just said cash
registers mm-hmm so how did you rate
your movie so I you calling it a movie
oh my god is this my first filmmaker
interview thank you welcome for the show
I was talking about devil I wasn't
talking about your video I didn't call
your video a movie pretentious little
why am i pretentious you just called it
a movie I did know I don't dabble the
move roll it back she caught up in a
movie thank you for thank you for
identifying my art Oh get out I did not
call your Aires season trailer art you
hey that when people say movie or short
film weren't [ __ ] no I'm okay with some
of it like okay if it has a storyline or
something like that
it's fiction and someone's like yeah
it's a short film or a movie I'm like
cool but like don't call your vlog a
movie you know what's today a vlogger
no okay anyway like a little trailer
like that's quite yeah I mean like a
little trailer but like no I'm not eclis
calling your long vlog of movies it
really bothers yeah I would echo that
that's not T at anybody in particular no
it's not it's a thing that I don't enjoy
yeah but it's also like so easy for
someone who has you know become popular
from vlogging or something like you to
be to decide that they're now a
filmmaker and just call her things films
but whatever anyway so I had this shot
in my head so I woke up this morning
kind of early and I was like okay let's
get a couple of shots right one of the
shots was like me grabbing coffee of the
fridge and then I was like like a fire
shot of the fireplace and then I was
like okay I really really don't want to
do this I was like more I was more
excited about it last night because I
don't know it's like when you're excited
about an idea and like you're at least
for me like at night I'm like all about
it I'm like so pod I'm like this is
gonna look so good I can't wait to do it
and then the morning comes I'm like [ __ ]
I don't want to do this you know I mean
I think that's normal so I woke up and I
was like I really don't do this it's
cold out it's like on and off raining
yeah you know that pool was freezing
cold
coolest [ __ ] coldest [ __ ] so I was
like alright I'll think about it maybe
I'll do it maybe I'll get some of the
other stress first and then it starts
[ __ ] pouring and I'm like okay this
is a sign I need to do it right now
so I cut a hole the size of my lens in
this box and I've taped plastic on top
of the box so that I can put my camera
on the rain and film without the lens
getting all watery and that's how you
got that child yeah I assumed you'd put
it like under the awning no because it
was a relatively wide lens so I brought
it right next to the edge of the pool
and I put it under the box ran upstairs
put on my button-down shirt ran back
down and just jumped in the pool cuz I
was like I just got to do this so I
jumped in the pool by the way it was
manual focus because I was terrified if
I had left it on auto it was gonna focus
on the bushes or whatever so I like I
tried to estimate where the focus
distance was I
it I got out soaking wet Hey look lift
up the box I'm like freezing cold I'm
like checking the shot like it's not
right like six times what I jumped back
in I'm probably got out Walker and one
time I actually emerged and started
coughing this is what's so cold I still
feel kind of like sick I hope I didn't
catch anything or I hope the neighbors
were watching the entire time yeah well
they they didn't pay admission so I hope
they didn't so after like six times I
finally feel like I got a decent shot so
I like bring the camera and bring my you
know I'd ride off run in I'm like huh
kind of still cold I'm like okay and so
that was like the catalyst that like
helped me shoot the rest of the video
cuz then I was like alright it's time to
go the rest is easy after that the rest
is easy after that was the hardest shot
then I did the cabinet opening scene and
then the shoe throwing scene and a
little of this little of that
see it's interesting to me as someone
that knows you to hear that you got the
hardest shot out of the way first
because that's something that I do I
push always to do like the worst first
unlike Julianne who when we first
started dating had saved your collective
Spanish working your second semester of
your senior year and you're taking this
like really hard Spanish class that you
passed a test in order to take and like
you were struggling so hard it was like
why would you save that for your last
semester of college it was G in Spanish
201 hellish [ __ ] horrible really
difficult class for you for your very
last semester of college it's brutal and
I should leave nothing hard for that so
all of your hard classes out of the way
freshman sophomore and junior year so
that you can chill a little bit and
start to like figure out your next steps
but not Julian it's literally like March
April and May and he's [ __ ] drowning
well if I might Wow defend myself here I
switched majors sophomore year so what
was your
major business administration I didn't
even know that you know I guess I didn't
think about it or I kind of just like I
knew at the time I kind of just did what
a couple of my other baseball friends
did we were like hey we're gonna play
baseball on City business man you know I
mean it's just kind of like what you did
I understand that so I my goal was to
like play baseball and like get drafted
so I signed up for Business
Administration nothing anything of it
end up getting injured stop playing
baseball and then I'm stuck in business
and I'm like really really not enjoying
it not like I can't do it like my grades
were okay yeah it was just I felt like
now that baseball I dropped out of my
life I needed to find a new interest or
purpose I feel like a lot of people
identify with all of a sudden realizing
your major is not something you're super
pumped about and changing it
yeah a lot of people that did the same
thing yeah and so so then I started
writing for the newspaper and I was like
journalism is cool and then I was like
yeah it's kind of old and then I found
broadcast journalism I was like okay
this is what I want to do but anyway in
that transition I like missed out on a
couple GES in my early like sophomore
year because I was switching majors so I
had to do I think my second semester of
my sophomore year my first semester my
junior year was like kinda nutty because
I had to do extra classes because I had
taken business classes when I should
have been taking my right you know in
your school had that what do you call
those January classes got inter term
yeah that was not a thing in my senior
term yeah and I had never heard of that
like join was taking inter term class so
it's during winter break you can take a
month-long like five days a week class
and it counts as a credit right and he
was always doing that I knew you and I
was like what is this [ __ ] I know it
sucks cuz all my friends went home for
like [ __ ] week a month and a half or
something like five weeks six weeks and
I was like therefore I was home for only
two a week and a half two weeks right
because I was at school studying but
when you're working yeah but anyway
Spanish just looked through the cracks a
little bit and I had to take an online
Spanish 201 my seniors some st in your
second semester and it was brutal
[ __ ] brutal because I was so rusty
and it was not a beginner's class it was
like intermediate because it's like the
third level it's like you at 101 102 and
then 201
one that explains a lot I guess yeah I'm
sure I knew that at the time but I just
the the idea always stuck with me that
you did that to yourself
and I just can't let it go I can't
believe that you did know I had to do it
or no you didn't have to do it you ever
thought about not doing it - it never
crossed my mind cuz I had to do it to
him I stayed doing it to him no you
didn't it's a state of mind I met Julian
when he was 20 I was 26 very scandalous
I know but so Julian while I was on
YouTube making videos and I had moved to
LA and I was here for a long time - I
met you so when we first started dating
Julian was still in college for a while
and like you were dating a college
student I was it was weird you know it
was weird but it was like at the same
time I I wasn't like your typical
college I was just like there for class
and then I was like working you know
yeah but it was weird though for me
because I had been out of college for
five years or well four years of
graduate school so it was weird to date
someone that was still like in that
environment because it had grown out of
it yeah in that amount of time for sure
and I would like tell you stories about
like things I saw on can your [ __ ]
teachers and [ __ ] I'm like oh my god
you're like what a trip I feel like I
had left that behind it was weird that
must have been weird because when you do
when you finish clock in college you do
close that door you [ __ ] slam it slam
I think she'll know more like especially
after going grad school - it's like you
close the door yeah when I had made the
decision that I wasn't gonna pursue a
PhD I was like I'm not gonna reopen the
store for many many years like I need to
go get some life experience you know so
that door was [ __ ] slammed and locked
you know until further notice yeah I
think that's why it's really difficult
for people like you know in their 20s
30s 40s 50s it's difficult to get back
in that mindset to go back to school
because it's you know once the balls
rolling you can keep it moving
but once that kinetic energy stops
you're sort of just like
[ __ ] that totally but like when I met
you we had sort of uh well you know we
were different in different stages of
life and there people it was like a lot
of factors there that would make it
difficult for a date we powered through
as friends we powered through best
friends Oh someone suggested we go on
our first date as in like one of us
asked each other out for a video I think
it'd be really funny imagine just tuning
into the podcast I would be like I don't
get it are they dating
they're just friends my favorite part
about that meme the fret as just friends
is like now when people are like get
married someone won't jump in and be
like oh they're just friends
we're just friends yeah for real what
but were you were just saying about real
like trying to get that momentum back
like our friend Grayson Matt if we met
gaming he just went back to school and
he's been telling me about like that
experience like studying for class again
and it's like and I kinda had a similar
thing where I was studying for the the
drone pilot exam and I hadn't exercised
those muscles in a long time yeah and it
felt weird so I hear you completely when
it's like going back to school is is a
[ __ ] compared to just like powering
through with that momentum that you have
as a young person well and people have
given me that advice when I was younger
too like if you can go to graduate
school after college like do it you know
because you're already in that mindset
and it's a lot easier you know
everyone's experience is totally
different and not everyone can do that
or wants to do that you know it's your
experience is your experience but my
experience is that it was easier
I imagine than if I decided now with my
life you know to go to college or back
to school because it's just it's hard
because college as hard as it is but
coming from a student mindset for that
many years in a row does have its
advantages yeah you know but like I was
one of the younger people in my graduate
program but I like a lot I was the
youngest but there was already little
one or two my people my age everyone
else was a little older and I always
remember feeling like like they took it
really seriously you know because when
you're like if I were to go back to
school today it's your money and you
understand the amount of time that goes
into it whereas when you're a student
sometimes it just feels like I go to
class it's what I do
you know it's my day I study it's like
already part of your life because that's
all you know but I always was you know I
found it really admirable to see adults
that were really passionate you're like
they had that little extra sort of like
excitement or like did so much of their
homework and they took everything so
seriously because that's like you know
their life they're really really
choosing to take time out of their this
organized thanks now for them yes yeah
and I just really appreciated that but I
think now I have a better perspective
understanding what that means to someone
to get their education at an older age
when you're a younger person sometimes I
feel like you take advantage of the fact
that understand you've only ever been a
student yeah and I don't want to come
off as like you know if you go to school
later on instead of finishing when
you're young you're bad like everyone
has different circumstances I'm not
judging anyone like I occasion is great
at anytime anytime yeah and you should
do whatever the [ __ ] you feel but that's
super interesting because singing back
to like you're anyone's mindset but like
my personal experience in college like
all I was thinking about was like just
get me the [ __ ] out just finish line
finish line finish line I can't wait to
go live your life where someone older
going back to school is really seeing
that as a great opportunity to further
their life where you're just like I
kinda start my life is never stored I
can't get out of this [ __ ] classroom
and they're like my life my life has
started and um it's [ __ ] hard so I'm
gonna need some help with a degree here
mm-hmm
yeah that's funny though anyways you
left that hard-ass spanish class for
your second semester of your senior year
and I couldn't believe you did that
yeah I'm surprised your boy got to be on
that you got that hardest class or the
hardest shot of your video filmed first
yeah it wasn't what I was planning
that's an Aries season mmm in this
climate you know it's a little out of
character to see you do the hardest
thing first well like a hardest thing
first person
no you know I get it done and then the
rest of it is okay I would say that I'm
the same though give me an example
oh let me think of one I don't know okay
you ever seen me carry one grocery bag
in at the time okay
fair but I'm not sure that that point
applies here why because that's just you
not wanting to make two trips sometimes
all trying to think like I had that
mindset and a lot of things cuz I'm like
like last night right I forgot I forgot
to put the dog food away we got the
shipment of dog food and I forgot to put
it away
and I also forgot to take out the
garbage bins mm-hmm right and it's late
and I'm like cold and I'm barefoot and
I'm fine run outside and I'm like okay
what's the hardest thing to do right now
well go outside of my bare feet and take
these bins out quietly cuz it's late to
the curb open the gate shut the gate you
know bring the rest of the boxes out do
it or you could just put the dog food
away and maybe do the bins of the
morning no I busted ass outside and I
was like hardest thing first carried
three bins at once not three two at once
and then that's what I mean so I anytime
have like chores I do the hardest on the
first see to me doing the hardest thing
first would be waking up knowing that
you have to take the garbage out that
day and doing all the things you don't
like in the day early and then later on
the day what about drinking about it
this is hard and I do it first everyday
it's your favorite thing it's hard
though no it is hard but that's you
doing what you want when you want to
that is that an example of getting the
hardest thing hunting the way first
there's that there is an example
somewhere is this conversation is Ares
season now there's an example you
defending yourself as to why you doing
things that you liked I'm allowed to
defend myself this month okay you have
to you have to give that to me every
other month has shut up this month I get
to defend myself wait what was that
every other month you shut up I'm told
I'm told to
in arguments I have to I have to
understand that like don't defend myself
but this month know that impulse is gone
okay yeah it is okay yeah yeah she's a
early Aries
why are you gonna blast me I didn't get
her anything get her something we'll go
shopping with me okay let's go tomorrow
well I could get her a class pass which
is a really awesome membership to where
you can work out at all sorts of
different types of gym so you don't get
bored with your workout guys class pass
is a really great service you don't want
to go to the same gym or the same
workout class we'll get back to it every
day or every week you're gonna get bored
right if you want to try kickboxing yoga
Pilates Krav Maga jiu-jitsu the best
sport of all time whatever weightlifting
CrossFit class pass is the is the it's
what it's for you it's really just made
for you okay it is actually an awesome
service to where you can live a lot of
different life experiences in the
fitness world with just one membership
and you don't have to worry about
signing up and then worrying about
cancelling like that's the best part is
the peace of mind with class pass they
provide all the options if you want to
lift really heavy things or if you want
to go spin like whatever it is they have
the options there for you and they give
so you sign up with class pass and then
they give you the list of all sorts of
the different gyms and options for
fitness classes in your area and you
just choose what you want and it has
worked for a lot of people and it can
work for you too right now get your
first two weeks for free free on class
pass calm / / try / Gemma Julian or
click the link down below I guarantee
you that if you try it you're gonna
probably do a fitness class that you did
not have in your future prior you
weren't gonna do it you weren't gonna
like get up and find that kickboxing
class for that size class what I want to
take a judoka you want take a judo class
people that don't want any good at judo
ship I just wanted to do it and try it
see you follow so it's tied up with
class pass you don't have to commit just
go through class
check it out guys go to class I just
burped into my class past calm / / Jenna
Julie also guys if you have a website
that you would like to build worry no
more because I can tell that you're
worrying I hear in your voice okay
go to Squarespace comm they are amazing
they have all the templates the features
and the ease of use really like the
functionality is so nice and simple with
Squarespace you have a vision for your
website they help you achieve it it's
really that simple and if you have
questions in the middle of that a
freaking night and you want help
Squarespace is there for you they have
24/7 award-winning customer support to
help you with your designs your fonts
your buttons how it looks on mobile how
it looks on desktop the colors whatever
it is they will help you and you can
make a really really bangin website and
a really really easy process so check it
out at Squarespace - all in one platform
and seriously like if you have questions
bother them that's their that's what
they're there for
ask them questions they will help you
and then you can make the website of
your dreams thank you
dream it make it with Squarespace right
now go to squarespace.com / agenda
Julian and you get 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain and also
dude what's on my butt right now me and
ease oh you got your pizza ones on
Kalama one is the new one
yeah it's like one of my favorite days
of the month when Squarespace oh my my
me Andy's package arrives and the same
beautiful little package and I open it
I'm like dude you know what made me feel
a little bit better today that I wasn't
gonna feel that good today some fresh
underwear
it makes honestly a [ __ ] difference
it does when you're like underwear is
nice and fun whereas I used to say cuz I
don't wear like underwire bras not much
really anymore but like if you're a bra
and your underwear match like holy [ __ ]
you think it's gonna be a good day it's
gonna be a good day and it's a brand new
design dude you didn't have to go
shopping for it you don't have to pick
out your size they know your size
they're me undies
guys check it out go to me undies
dot-com slash into Julien okay and check
their stuff out that you get to fifteen
percent of your first pair of free
shipping and if you don't like it for
whatever reason they will take it back
Andra fund you for your purchase they
have Sox brought let's underwear they
have hats they have onesies which we
love so much check them out
click the link below thank you to our
sponsors thank you sponsors this really
is like the bra let's are such a good
like I'm chillin around the house bra
you know I'm not gonna do or tell me
what that means cuz I don't know you
don't understand no I just mean like
explain no explain it to me like because
I know I've heard you say and girls say
like taking my bra off at the end of the
day is so nice like it feels good but
like that one feels good to wear so it's
like which one is it I just want to know
like you want me to explain bras well I
think it's kind of interesting I love
being friends we're just friends I need
to know so and I stopped wait I feel
like I stopped wearing underwire bras
unless I was like I don't there's been
times I've worn like a gown or something
like a wedding that we go to or
something like that where I'm wearing
like a dress and you need like evens out
your shape a little more when you have
like padding we're looking underwear bra
but you know when I was growing up that
was like what we had really we had
sports bras training bras or like you
know thin little for like 12 year olds
or whatever and then like underwire bras
and you know obviously there's different
types and different kinds but like the
norm was that's a type of rosin
underwear bra like that's an an
underwire underwire are these an
underwear bra okay no so it literally
has a wire underneath the cup yeah
so it's like holding it and shaping it
yes and it just over time just starts to
feel like you're wearing a wire yeah it
sounds painful and even by the time I
was like you know 20 or whatever there's
much more comfortable bras like they
they don't have an underwire or if they
do they're like a lot nicer and don't
feel like that
but that whole like it just doesn't feel
that good you know yeah if you wear it
like you put it on when I was a kid you
put it on it [ __ ] 6:00 in the morning
you might take it off for gym class but
like you're wearing all [ __ ] day and
it's like Chris that's against you yeah
right I can imagine that'd be like
uncomfortable so I get straps are
cutting into you and stuff but like to
wear sports bras mostly bras bra let's
like like looser stuff guys cuz if I'm
this is just me this is a personal
preference it would be TMI but like and
I'm just like walking around without a
bra with like a loose shirt like it
starts to get uncomfortable like yeah
nipples are well they fee I can see that
I mean if I walk around in the wrong in
the wrong type of shirt yeah the wrong
weather humidity or whatever yeah it's
good it's like that up to the office
when Andy run the marathon sorry totally
I don't get that at all they ran a 5k
and he taped his nipples with an X
underneath his shirt so he had hot sure
but like I like to wear unless I'm you
know going to the gym we're going to
work out or whatever
I'll wear sports bra for the most part
or if I'm around the house if I'm
wearing no bra that's fine but I can't
do that like all day and all night yeah
yeah unless I'm wearing like a really
tight shirt or something then that's
probably fine but like if it's just like
a loose t-shirt then I'll wear like a
bralette rod like like those like lacy
ones that are just like a halter yeah
just something chill yeah you know I
feel you I feel like I would like I
would have the same kind of preference
if I wore bras like a chill bra a chill
bra chill
come on brah get out no come back come
back friend here shall we grab lunch as
friends I want the check because we're
friends I always so when I played sports
and stuff I would wear multiple sports
bras because when I was in college they
were very expensive to buy a sports bra
and yeah you know you could buy ones
from like Nike or Under Armour and it
just wasn't I don't know I felt like
they weren't everywhere you know nor was
it like fashionable to where you can go
to forever 21 and find
like a sports bra top you know it wasn't
like outerwear it wasn't like a sure
they were sports specific and they were
undergarments kind of so I would wear
multiple sports bras because some of
them [ __ ] sucks yeah cheap so we're
like three sports bras to my softball
game like at once in order to keep them
all together
gotta keep them under control you know
gotta keep them together even together
the whole team's got to be together okay
now I can wear one sports bra because
I'm not doing as vigorous as of
activities and they're also better
quality now mmm what a time to be alive
that's like all I wear
yeah like I feel like some of my shirts
look better two of the more use for its
raw yeah I agree I think they look good
on you with a shirt on and just the
sports bra I know we're just friends I
shouldn't be looking but this is
completely platonic oh yeah your
stalkers were the cue by the way thank
you yeah especially an Aries season you
can try maybe make a noise so he knows
you're coming
conquer go okay he's not no his eyes are
still closed no no okay wait maybe pet
him the next time I come over for a
playdate with you okay yeah I'll then
may you my address
so anyway yep I went for a nice little
cold swim long story short I went for a
cold swim this morning and I still have
a headache from it for whatever reason
are you gonna get sick is that what is
that what that means probably huh like
it's like when you get stuck in the rain
and it's cold and then you know the next
day you feel kind of sniffily well you
might not get like a full-blown cold but
yeah your body's like [ __ ] you yeah a
little while later I went in the hot
shower and I could tell it was too late
well you know some days you anyway
looks it is I don't know finish your
sentence some days you what you wake up
knee-high on the grass patching them
back
okay how about that okay what tell me
what I did you're making me feel weak
okay well so it's just another day then
we had I've had multiple people come to
the house and we haven't got rid of
those [ __ ] jeans they're just sitting
in the office
yeah like pairs of legs yeah they look
like I mean we look like freaky people
because we have tripods everywhere and
we have legs just sitting around our
house yeah stuffed legs stapled together
yeah and then beautiful plants but also
we're really cute really weird
where are they weird people were really
ready that's why I was hoping our
neighbors we were watching you while you
were jumping in onto the pool in a shirt
with an umbrella yeah I mean they
actually got trapped on one take cuz I
was like trying to push the umbrella and
ain't like there's suctioned into the
water and I was like is it a little
drugstore umbrella so it was really
getting tossed around by the wake that
our pool was making from the lay rain in
our Southern California it'll wake that
the rain was making it was actually my
wake the way that I was making
I make awake that make wake so how about
how about airplane food special
shout-out to Chris he just put on a
really cool video we were talking about
doing this but we haven't really even
like talked about it further organize it
but it would be cool like shout people
out on like a regular thing if we could
you know make that part of the podcast
or every other podcast or whatever were
I think like I'm literate I'd said to
you I think we should make like a
beginning little thing in the podcast
yeah we just talk about something that
that we found like well I'll start it
off Chris malboro just he made like a
sequel to his video if
Shane Dawson edited normal dudes lives
but he instead of just like kind of
redoing the same video in a sequel
format he came up with his really really
funny concept and it's really good he
liked and he got all these Viners to
send in this like kind of a little home
tape that fits right into the story and
it's really funny but anyway that was
like that was my favorite watch of the
week what was yours well and he's almost
at a hundred thousand you go sub to him
dude I have literally no link these
below I think I had made a note on my
like Gmail notes or whatever it
literally it just said I made this on
October 18th 2018 that's a long time ago
that's right well that's when I was like
we should do a thing in the beginning or
some part of the podcast where we just
talk about something that we really like
yeah and I had written
Jenna's random good thoughts for
podcasts like I just yeah yeah yeah for
sure I wish I had my soundboard a random
good stop for the podcast like I'm gonna
tell you something that was really nice
this week and I have written down
because I was watching an interview I
think like on the red carpet Grammys or
some awards show yeah we're BTS was and
I think pretty sure it's named June of
BTS I read written has really
astoundingly good English and that's
really cool because I was like I'm
thinking about right if you're an
english-speaking pop star and you're in
a group say with your friends and people
that you trust yeah it feels really good
but everything you know how hectic and
award show is in the first place yeah
you're in another country and there's
all of these media interview people that
you don't know you don't watch their
shows yes you don't know what the hell's
[ __ ] happening there's sensory
[ __ ] overloads really loud and your
English is only like okay at this and
it's just [ __ ] terrified yeah like is
this person saying something mean to me
are they being disrespectful towards me
like I don't [ __ ] know because I only
no conversational Japanese and I was
watching this interview and namjoon like
has really really really really good
English and you could just tell how much
more comfortable it made all of them
feel and that it was just like it just
was [ __ ] amazing like I I couldn't
like he would step in or like sort of
reassure one of the you know whoever
speaking like help them finish their
sentence or help them clarify and like
that's so [ __ ] rad like it's really
[ __ ] rad and we see like athletes and
people where they have a translator
talking after a fight like for U of C
and how scary it must be to be in that
position and not speak English but to
have someone that you trust that like
has your back one of your boys help you
do that and like know that you're not no
one's talking down to you or doing
anything like that you're just like
really [ __ ] cool that's super rad
yeah super rad and I think that's like
one of those things that a lot of people
overlook especially in that sort of
setting where it's like big deal like
you know whatever but it's like if you
actually think about what their
experience is like at an event like that
yeah because a lot of people detach
their feelings for a celebrity or an
artist from that of a humans whereas
like your mother or your brother
you don't detach those emotions because
I know that they're people so like if
you really think about it man that's
like it's an intense thing and like it's
a really cool skill that provides a
level of like emotional safety oh yeah
think about okay so the people in BTS
are any any group that doesn't speak
English and one of those boys is your
son and that boy is like you know what
the whim of their manager or their agent
New York they go wherever they got it's
all business that's their job but like I
in my heart of hearts want to make sure
that someone's looking out for them you
know on an emotional level is he okay
how is he doing and that's what NAMM
june was doing in that interview you
know it seems like he does a lot and it
was just like it just made me feel
really like happy you know yeah
how scary is that it's I would be I
would just like clam up you know if I
didn't like you've been to other
countries where you don't speak the
language and they start laughing you're
like oh my god I did it yeah are you
laughing at me yeah
really out of place and like scared
you're hoping you're not offending
anyone while at the same time yeah also
self-conscious you're like completely
self-conscious yeah yeah yeah
it reminds me of like watching the
difference between watching like a
translator sorry someone who does who
like signs at a concert or a speech hmm
but the difference being someone who's
super enthusiastic about it versus
someone who's maybe not as enthusiastic
it's like night and day
yeah and you see someone really getting
into it whether it's like a song or
whatever or it's a passionate speech or
something you see that they're like
really trying to convey what this person
saying and now what they mean when
they're saying and where it comes from I
don't know I think that's like super
special thing like translating languages
or signing to people who are deaf or
hard of hearing so that's cool
would that be like the coolest
superpower though to speak every
language there's someone out there who
does it yeah they probably work for the
[ __ ] FBI CIA or some [ __ ] how many
languages are there I actually don't
know the answer to that don't me to look
it up no I'd rather not know
[Laughter]
a hundred give us some Spanish from that
really hard Spanish class that you took
your ombre Oh si mucho hambre
okay tienes baseball muchísimo nosotros
cough a husky father he taught me
encanta cafe no me gusta la Julian si si
pero it's like a little the beginning
Paquita it's like the beginning of this
sentence starts off okay and then it
just turns into words you know si
Delgado Julian Gordo muchísimo you
should say this but rappy that meant
there now you're just saying words rapid
I meant this when we were walking the
dogs the other day a woman was jogging
bat-like past us with her phone out
speaking into it in front of her face
dude in Spanish and I was like damn get
it my mom does that she jogs with her no
she
does this thing she does sounds good
period I'll I'll call you back
hold on one second one second Joe in the
morning and then it beeps and it stops
listening they're like halfway through
and she reads it back and it didn't even
[ __ ] copy anything she's saying she
does it again
what is the Harmon and just writing it
out I don't think my mom knows how to
use that feature no your mom knows
Howard she knows how bad it is really
yeah I mean I get like text to speech or
speech to text or whatever you know to
do but when you're doing it like this
and you're multitasking like my mom the
true Ares that she is and also like not
really speaking Siri friendly you know
like you're not an unseating originally
yeah well I'll call him in a little bit
and she's like ordering or like dealing
with like the mail Anders yeah how is
this she's like I was that pretty sort
of efficient it's that's really
frustrating when you're working like
that you're working at a place and that
person's on the phone on the phone
texting yeah with speech and this is
like a universal like parent phone phone
mission yeah it's like it's holding it
up to your mouth yeah or if they're
texting it's like either like this yeah
really far away or really close up I
used to make fun of my dad because he
anytime we go out to dinner he would the
check would come and he would he would
pull the check this whole thing but he
could see because his food was right
here the whole time
and somehow the check it's not words
okay but also it was fun a terrible
eyesight I can tell you yeah my dad has
bad eyesight it was fun to make fun of
him food as a child normally does to
their parents so I used to make fun of
him that like every time the check would
come here he would pull out his long and
then we just get further and further
every time but no parents parents be
like you know they really didn't see the
number on the check so you leave a tip
for a 10% or 15% of something else yeah
some other number that you got use that
yeah like ignorant says bliss you know I
don't think about it and whatever
tip your waiters yes please that's the
best and bartenders and bartenders of
course you think you're so funny making
fun of your dad's dad I say I'm looking
you now be glad you can't die because
look who doesn't have to wear her
glasses look I can read things tell me
this is Apollo that says preempt that
says iso 800 we're all so impressed with
your eyesight except the next time that
you go to take your DMV test or whatever
you're gonna have to do an eye test and
unless you bring your glasses you're not
gonna pass or I could show up to the
rest of our life or I could show up and
they say take your eye exam and I just
be like nah you're like that's that no
I'll get my license oh I know a guy who
works at the DMV you knew you were gonna
say I know I say that a lot yes okay I
do know a guy oh you as a friend so well
first of all you don't know a guy second
of all I knew your guy
third of all whenever he started telling
a joke and it sort of like ends with a
bizarre premise you always go and then
he woke up it was all a dream
don't he realize he was at a massive
acid trip the attack I don't know he was
at home he was in a hole I appreciate
that you think you know how my comedy
works and how my storytelling is
structured but it is an ever-evolving
one mm-hmm so I was you might think I
was gonna say I know a guy right yeah
even though I didn't say it he did roll
it back I didn't say it I said I was
gonna say I used to work at the DMV
which is also a lie but I did I did work
there yeah I know where they keep their
files and I know where they keep more
importantly the the material of which
they make driver's license out of a I
also know a guy who can make a driver's
license off market so I was gonna steal
one of the sheets of material bring it
to my guy he'll take half of the sheets
as payment and then I'll get a free
driver's license with seeing whatever
the [ __ ] I wanted to say on their
illegal address name cuz I color I'm a
forged my color wait now that you're
talking about this I'm
being about what I was thinking about
this the other day my weight says
something it's totally not on my license
because it's like old and I'm like
someday I'm gonna get pulled over by a
cop and he's just gonna look at me and
go that's not what you weighed identity
theft
I'm pretty sure it says no one has the
same weight for years and years I mean
it's like everyone's always if anything
it's height if you were a different
height then that would be that would
raise more sure yeah it says my hair is
blonde on here because it was my hair
was blonde okay here and wait maybe you
might be getting to a little suspicious
territory I'm like I'm 32 years old but
I still get like fear that someone's
gonna look at my license and go that's
not you that's not you it's here
it's not it's you it's you with
different color hair more makeup and
there's a signature right beneath your
neck but I don't see it on your real
body
I don't have my license on me but what
do I look like in mine I don't remember
my my favorite thing though is when you
were like literally like a 7 year old
child in your passport travel boogie
your password laughing I hadn't taken a
new password bigger for years I had
walked around a passport with me I think
of like 15 years old well into my 20 10
years so yeah but I also think I renewed
at once but didn't renew the picture
somehow and so we went to like Australia
it was a favorite cuz he just looked at
you and started [ __ ] dying laughing
it's like you grew you changed a little
bit like yeah I was like a literal child
and then on my most recent passport
picture I have just sweet mustache so I
actually don't know what I was gonna say
after that but I have a mustache when I
passed my picture so yeah I guess I I
don't I can't think of what your license
picture it looks like right now my
license picture is me with blonde hair
off to the side but honestly I kind of
want to refer
back to my 18 year old picture because I
think I look better in that one wait you
can't do that I might I will see a guy I
just do when I bring your own SD card
and when I swap it out of their camera
it was just like a glamour of full body
shot I'm like a photo set when I took
this license picture I'm pretty sure
this was either the first or second
license picture that I got in California
I think this one might be my second but
the thing is your second the first one
that I took she didn't tell me she was
taking the picture yeah you know she's
just trying to push people in and out of
there so she's just like okay here's
your thing and then she just flicks it
at him he's like you know I get to like
the flare so she takes there's you know
three pictures and only one of them I
had my eyes opened so that was the
default one she was which one do you
want it was like well I guess that one
like should I pick one with my eyes shut
for my license lady she wouldn't even
let me retake it this one I remembered
they had let me retake it cuz you did
the same thing your eyes are closed for
half of them mm-hmm not because I wasn't
paying attention but because they just
[ __ ] did it like a nice little 1 2 3
might be helpful or something well I
support you 100% but there are two sides
to every story and I would like to talk
to the woman who took the picture to see
what her experience was cuz maybe yeah
maybe you weren't listening well from my
first license went like right when I
turned 16 or whatever I didn't because
I'm dumb because I'm 16 or whatever I
didn't realize that they took your
picture that day I thought you know they
were gonna take it some other that's
adorable so I went in there and I just
looked like sweatshirt did you pass your
driver's that's the first time yeah nice
do you think I did
oh boy yeah I think you did well though
well we took driver's ed and stuff in
high school it was so of course you
could take your high school it was hard
to get into we do not have that dude
yeah we had we had like wood work but
not driver's ed cuz like you need to
learn to work with wood but you don't
need to learn to drive a [ __ ] car I
guess skill that I wish that I had I
wish that I had taken woodshop hello
that's [ __ ] great I don't
actually a woodchopper class would be
cool but like there was a lot of
extraneous classes that you could take
as your electives like junior and senior
year that people just did nothing in
like my film class I took it because my
dad was like take the film class because
I had to choose between that and like
ceramics ceramics another one like great
if that's your hobby but I'm sorry here
we're trying to prepare you for
adulthood learn how to make a [ __ ]
pot and make it even with your thumbs
and glaze it keep your thumbs on the
outside while it spins use the pedal I
agree that driver's ed is a very
valuable class and should have been
offered at your school but I think years
old taxes to that totally a couple years
after I graduated they had done away
with they got rid of it because it
wasn't enough funding for it well that's
like one of the first things to go there
was actually an auto shop class towards
like my senior year I think it so said
but I was too late or whatever but they
had like a garage and you could look
learn how to work on cars yeah I would
have taken that well I just think it's
valuable because for my you know my
family like my dad was a decent teacher
for driving but like I didn't live with
him you know yeah I saw him on you know
we every weekend but when I would try
and learn how to drive from my mother it
was like some of the most stressful
[ __ ] moments of my life because she's
just holding on to the [ __ ] bar the
whole time so terrified and like it's
very difficult to learn with something
like that type of energy going on but
that's cuz we lived together to my
mother you know but there it's common
that not every fifteen-year-old
that is ready to get their license you
know whether they have a car that they
can use when they turn 16 or not like
not everyone has a parent that's even
willing to total we were both kind of
like driver's ed was a class that you
could take and you could learn how to
drive yeah my dude oh god I remember
every time I would get behind the wheel
my dad would grab the thing and he would
just like brace himself for a [ __ ]
accident it's really difficult to learn
in that environment for like well well
could you stop that maybe and it's like
he wants to stop but he's also genuinely
thinking that he might like
like brace room I learned how to drive
on a standard car and then I drove a
standard car for a lot of years I mean
like a manual transition yeah so it is
like there's definitely a lot more like
stalling out that happens while you're
learning it I still don't know so I feel
I like I understand that aspect of it
like if you're teaching someone how to
drive a stick shift it is like you know
you might jerk around a little bit but
for like an automatic car I know tell my
dad that when I was falling like 15
miles an hour for so much of the
learning process like I promise you it's
gonna be okay yeah yeah I mean I don't
know I haven't taught a 16 year old how
to drive so but relinquishing control
especially was your car to a kid that
you know very well might crash like that
but that's being a parent it's like okay
I anyone that's scared in that situation
go go get in a driver's ed car with four
other kids that don't know how to
[ __ ] Drive Alisha bans the real
heroes you have a safety wheel and pedal
though he did
well I took driver's ed with a girl that
like the only real time I was scared in
that car with those other kids
was she we were driving on so you do
like city driving you do like an upstate
New York you have some country driving
dirty roads there's a little bit of
different situation than highway driving
John Verney oh yeah so we're on one of
these like country roads it's two lanes
you know there's one going this way and
one coming this way
so it follows different rules with your
hash to is in the center people pass you
know all kinds of [ __ ] so usually
there's no like stoplights or anything
you just there's a turn and you take it
that's it yeah she did not understand
that like these the speed limits like 45
50 miles an hour in these roads yeah she
did not understand that you have to slow
down the car in order to turn so she
just he's like okay you know in the next
you know hundred feet or whatever you're
gonna you're gonna take a left or 300
feet whatever so she's just like she's
gonna [ __ ] die and he slams on his
[ __ ] student brake or whatever in
that's the sort of thing like but he
stays so common yeah yeah that's the
real in order to take through in order
to take a turn you know we you have to
slow down she's like oh I'm sorry you
just didn't think of it it's okay yeah
you just keep going yeah that's the
that's the sort of thing though like I
can imagine my 15 year old self thinking
like a u-turn yeah that's so funny whips
it around a corner
can you imagine yeah that sounds [ __ ]
you sound like you're gonna roll and
you're just like okay this is it I mean
like a minivan ma'am oh we did it yeah
my mom had the Euro van growing on man
first of all that thing was not easy to
drive second of all we didn't drive it
legally a lot of time because the back
folded up into like a bed and you're not
supposed to drive with it like that but
we did because you could buckle in while
you're laying completely flat so we
would lay completely flat on the back
and buckle in sardines yeah I'm like
road trips and stuff when we're going up
to five you know me California stuff yes
you would turn around if you're driving
it's just like one little like bed and
there's just the kids on it it was semi
safe he's probably not the best idea you
can never drive with the pop-up open
though because that would have like had
allowed the car to drive yeah I use my
my friend the load of the street for me
her parents had a Volvo and in the 90s
they like the station wagon they had
these little tiny seats that folded down
in the trunk and you sat backwards you
sat I remember that exact car I remember
that car we just thought it was like the
most fun the coolest thing ever
you would always want those seats yeah
hell yeah you wave at other cars you're
like watching you're like you're like
the pilot pretty much you're in a
cockpit you but as a kid you're like
this is my [ __ ] car now
I imagine that that car was marketed to
people as like a seven passenger vehicle
right one two three four five six seven
yeah yeah but it's there's you're
sitting on the ground yeah it's just
like a seat that was propped into the
treats
seat belt on the back of the back seats
yes so it's very like after body your
feet are like you're sitting in the
trunk on us you know quote-unquote seat
but it's not like your legs have leg
you're not sitting in a chair no on the
truck with your legs crossed on the
floor of the truck backwards facing out
in hindsight probably not that safe
still absolute blast as a kid total I've
sat in that car before it was [ __ ]
great yeah and my uncle's pickup truck
like in the back of the had like a you
know extra big cabinet yeah so behind
this passenger seat and the driver's
seat maybe sometimes it was like a bench
seat but there was too little literally
just folds down his seat and he loved
that yeah I thought that was the most
fun thing in the whole world
we were sat in the bed of a car when you
when you like the bed of a truck when he
was driving [ __ ] no it's legal I did
that what's wrong with you it wasn't a
smart thing but I do I didn't really
have much of a choice
so if I wanted a ride that's how I was
getting a ride it was very recent to
Julian it wasn't that recent it was what
Julian okay we were shooting behind the
scenes for middlin in Austin can you
guess it was with Collin we were in
Austin okay oh but that's like a thing
you were you in Texas we're we're in
Austin so but I know people do it I
still wasn't comfortable but it was like
you know we were going to one of their
houses to drop some stuff off and then
we're gonna go out how fast did you go
no more than 25 25 still too fast no
more we were going on in Congress it
wasn't a bit it wasn't like a highway
it's like it is legal in Texas probably
but I think it's one of those laws were
it's like illegal but also like we're
not gonna really put their dogs in the
back of a no I've seen that a lot
actually
with like big dogs bad you'll like the
laws regarding dogs and cars are very
like not clear are there I know in other
I think in the UK I don't know them
correct me if I'm wrong but I'm pretty
sure I read the other day that if a dog
is in your car and
somewhere I think I know you're talking
about and you get in an accident and the
dog gets hurt or something it negates
your insurance so for certain types of
accidents because so it's it's basically
like if there's a dog loose in the car
we're not gonna cover you if you get in
an accident you need to make sure that
your dog is safe and that is it dogs for
babies oh my god oh my god no I'm sorry
about babies
okay there's dogs okay just making sure
it's basically I think the idea behind
it is if if your dogs loose and running
around in your car it's probably a
distraction so we're not gonna cover you
if you get in an exit I did yes I
remember that but that's it's not like
that's something you need to have your
dog restrained in a certain way in your
car but that's the only that's the only
law of that sort I've ever heard of yeah
but like brushed up on [ __ ] but I
think just the ever like the everyday
person knows laws without being a lawyer
they see people with dogs loose in their
car people with dogs in the back of
their pickup drugs people with dogs
wherever people with dogs who are like
very aggressively putting their heads
all the way out the back window so
they're going really fast and I'm just
like do you like really trust that dogs
yeah so I don't know - Jackie her dog
baby would like it was her happy place
to jam her whole head out the window and
bark into the air and my favorite was
when we would go into the tunnels yeah
and she would hear her own bark so every
can go into touch with [ __ ] echoing
in the tunnel she loved it what girl
what are you barking at just the wind
if Marvel could reach that high he would
do the same [ __ ] thing
he likes to relax in the car he's a good
boy he does not like to relax the car he
he makes noises that a chimpanzee makes
when we're pulling up to the dog park or
our walk but that's when we're there cuz
he's excited yeah we're driving he's a
good boy
they have a car seat they do peach makes
me nervous sometimes because she'll leap
out of her car seat and put her hands on
my left shoulder while I'm driving and
she'll just appear there next to me
until we needed shorten her yeah she's
got a long leash on that harness but
yeah cheers friend truth friend
well happy Harry's season to all of you
guys we'll be we'll be back with another
area season podcast for like a whole
month baby it's just getting started and
boy I need a car seat for Aries season
please just like in the house yeah
turn you into a Bubble Boy they put you
in there yes please
we should go on our first date sometime
anyway thank you guys for listening to
the podcast maybe oh did I just get
denied I know but I'm oh damn
okay fair enough well pray for me I'm in
the friend zone
okay Bernie it's Aries we'll see you
guys next week be loud and be proud it's
air season bye
[Music]